all of the late night talk shows have
been on Hiatus for several months now
because of the writers strike this comes
as news to most Americans who had
forgotten that those shows existed late
night talk shows of course haven't been
relevant least of all funny since
approximately maybe the year 2003. in
fact I was surprised to learn that they
were impacted by The Writer's strike at
all as I assumed that they didn't have
writers but they do and in spite of the
strike and the general lack of relevance
one late night show has managed to make
the news this week for all the wrong
reasons Rolling Stone has the big expose
on The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
here's the headline chaos comedy and
crying rooms inside Jimmy Fallon's
Tonight Show 16 current and former
staffers say Fallon's erratic Behavior
spoiled their dream of working on The
Tonight Show
now as you can tell from the title this
is yet another shocking report about a
so-called toxic work environment we're
seeing these kinds of uh things with
increasing frequency you might even say
that the the toxic work environments are
having their me too moment first it was
Ellen Degeneres then earlier this year
thanks to another Rolling Stone expose
we heard that the Kelly Clarkson show is
a toxic environment where employees feel
stressed out and they get yelled at
sometimes and they start crying and
their mental health is severely impacted
then a few weeks ago the American
Psychological Association released a new
study claiming that
uh 20 of all workers In America which is
about 30 million people give or take are
in workplaces that are toxic and half of
them say that their mental health has
been harmed by all the toxicity in the
workplace and now we have this
Revelation about Jimmy Fallon toxic work
environments are an epidemic it seems
which raises the question what exactly
is a toxic work environment and how does
it significantly differ from a regular
work environment let's read a little bit
of this Rolling Stone report to see if
it might help illuminate the issue for
us quote according to two current and 14
former employees The Tonight Show has
been a toxic workplace for years far
outside the boundaries of what's
considered normal in the high pressure
world of late night TV they say the ugly
environment behind the scenes starts at
the top with Fallon's erratic behavior
and has trickled down to its
ever-changing leadership teams nine
showrunners in the past nine years who
seemingly don't know how to say no to
Jimmy former employees describe the
Tonight Show as a as a 10 cent pretty
glum atmosphere with some alleging that
they were belittled and intimidated by
their bosses including Fallon himself
employees describe being afraid of
felons outbursts and unexpected
inconsistent Behavior seven former
employees say that their mental health
was impacted by their alleged
experiences working at The Tonight Show
these staffers say it was commonplace to
hear people joking about wanting to kill
themselves and that they would refer to
guest dressing rooms in the office as
crying rooms because that's where they
would go to let out their emotions when
they are upset with their alleged
mistreatment
well
this sounds uh potentially bad so far
employees are breaking down in tears at
work they're talking about killing
themselves
what exactly is happening to these
people
like what is Jimmy Fallon doing to them
like what specifically is he doing what
terrible atrocities are being inflicted
upon the Tonight Show staff
well let's keep reading we'll find out
quote it's a bummer because it was my
dream job one former employee says
writing for for late night is a lot of
people's dream jobs and they're coming
into this and it becomes a nightmare
very quickly it's sad that it's like
that especially knowing that it doesn't
have to be this way but behind the
scenes there was a surprising dramatic
and ugly shift in the working
environment according to three employees
who originally worked for Late Night
with Jimmy Fallon and Then followed the
team to The Tonight Show of course there
was the added pressure when the program
transitioned The Tonight Show was one of
the television's most storied franchises
quote The Producers felt this pressure
and that translated down to all their
employees people that worked under them
and then felt this pressure that if you
made one mistake you were gone and would
be easily replaced one former employee
says quote you have all these NBC pages
in the building who are ready willing
and waiting to take your job
okay at this point we've learned that
some of the employees expected the job
to be a dream and it wasn't and they
also felt a lot of pressure and they
were afraid that they might be fired and
replaced
so far it sounds like this toxic work
environment is just literally every work
environment are you one of the millions
of American men and women dealing with
premature hair thinning and hair loss or
maybe you're scared about inheriting
that thinning look because it runs in
the family well finally there's a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and unpleasant smells provia
Hair Care uses a safe natural ingredient
called procapital to effectively Target
the three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss Previa supports
healthy scalp circulation it delivers
nourishing nutrients to strengthen hair
follicles and anchor them to your scalp
provia guarantees more hair on your head
than in the shower drain which is what
you want provia is effective for men and
women of any age and safe on color
treated and styled hair provio Works
guaranteed or 100 of your money back
it's that easy right now new customers
save over 50 percent off probio's
introductory package of proviahair.com
Walsh see results for yourself right now
don't wait that's proviahair.com Walsh
before giving our dog rough greens he
was so sad and lazy well now he actually
enjoys his squeaky toys and playing
Fetch with his frisbee our pup's days
are filled with laughter exercise and
endless fun naturopathic Dr Dennis black
the founder of rough grains is focused
on improving the health of every dog in
America little did I know before I got
rough grains that dog food is dead food
everybody knows that nutrition isn't
Brown it's green well let rough grains
boost your dog's food back to life rough
grains is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough Greens on their
food every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about rough grains that supports
healthy joints improves bad breath
boosts energy levels and so much more we
are what we eat and that goes for dogs
too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is so
confident rough greens will improve your
dog's health he's offering my listeners
a free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try up a free jumpstart trial bag
could be at your door in just a few
business days go to roughgreens.com Matt
or call 844 rough 700 it's Ruff greens
dot com slash Matt or call 844 rough 700
today
but maybe we haven't gotten to the
really horrific stuff yet so let's uh
continue
quote nobody told Jimmy no everybody
walked on eggshells especially show
Runners another former employee says you
never knew which Jimmy you were going to
get when he was going to throw a hissy
fit look how many show Runners went so
quickly we know they didn't last long
with an ever-changing cast at the top
employees say that they had nightmares
related to work and were in a constant
state of fear one former police says
that they had their first anxiety attack
while working at the show and were put
on anti-anxiety medication for the first
time another employee says that they
felt physical ramifications of their
declining mental health like their hair
thinning and weakened nail beds four
other employees say that they're in
therapy because of their experiences
three say they experience suicidal
ideation as a result of the working
environment one employee says that they
lost nearly 20 pounds during their time
working under showrunner granite
biederman and felt like they were on
edge all the time and cried themselves
to sleep every night
so
we're still hearing about the emotional
Devastation all these employees
experience crying themselves to sleep
every night crying at work crying
everywhere all the time in therapy
losing weight
we haven't heard what exactly happened
to them to justify this kind of reaction
from the sound of it these people are
are having the emotional reaction you'd
expect from someone who's I don't know
whose house just burned down with their
entire family inside I mean they are
describing deep profound emotional
trauma crying yourself to sleep every
night that's like
grieving the loss of a loved one okay so
what could possibly have happened to
them at the office to cause this kind of
reaction we still haven't heard so let's
continue
according to most employees who spoke to
Rolling Stone it's common knowledge that
behind the scenes uh Fallon's
temperament mood and treatment of
staffers is erratic these employees say
that they've witnessed Fallon's snap at
crew members Express irritation over the
smallest of things but rate and belittle
staffers out of frustration three four
employees say that he berated them in
front of other colleagues and grew and
crew members one employee says that
depending on Fallon's mood they felt
like his notes and feedback could be
passive aggressive personal insults as
opposed to constructive criticisms they
say that he would write comments like
are you okay seriously do you need help
Rolling Stone reviewed photos of the
employees alleged notes from Fallon that
read Ugg lame what is going on with you
you've outdone yourself
the same employees say that Fallon would
also send combative emails one of which
was reviewed by Rolling Stone to certain
staffers if he was dissatisfied with
their work two employees remember
witnessing Fallon scold the crew members
cre crew member who was in charge of his
cue cards in the middle of a taping with
comedian Jerry Seinfeld they say it was
an uncomfortable moment
okay I can just stop this here and spoil
the ending uh because this is it
there is no shocking Revelation about
horrific abuse being inflicted upon upon
tonight's show staffers like it's just
this
the boss gets angry sometimes and yells
he criticizes employees who dissatisfy
him on occasion there's some passive
aggressiveness
sometimes people get fired
the closest thing they get to an actual
shocker is that two employees claim that
Fallon seemed potentially inebriated at
work once six years ago
which if true of course is bad
but there is nothing here that could
even remotely justify crying fits and
panic attacks and employees running
around threatening suicide
okay this is not a toxic work
environment it's a it's a fragile work
environment staffed by a collection of
emotionally stunted crybabies who break
down in tears if they experience a
little bit of pressure or if the boss
gets a little bit a little bit mad
sometimes
look I'm no Jimmy Fallon fan I have no
dog in this fight
I have no instinct to defend him or any
real interest in defending him
but my general ambivalence towards Jimmy
Fallon is overridden in this case by the
intense revulsion I feel towards this
generation of overgrown children
masquerading as adults who can't handle
even the smallest amount of stress
and that's where this idea of the toxic
work environment comes from
now there might be some workplaces that
really are toxic in a more significant
sense but for the most part when someone
complains about their workplace being
toxic what they really mean is that
their workplace is a workplace that they
have to deal with other people they have
responsibilities they have to perform
you know they they have to justify their
existence and their job there's pressure
there's stress
tempers flare sometimes people disagree
co-workers and bosses have
eccentricities that can be annoying and
frustrating
it's a workplace it's life as an adult
this is how it goes
now just to drive the point home here
recently Forbes published a list of the
10 signs that you're in a toxic
workplace and and here are some of the
signs
uh it says that your workplace is toxic
says Forbes
if you are physically and mentally
exhausted at the end of each workday If
your manager asks you to be available to
answer emails in the evenings
if your colleagues complain about work
or if your co-workers sometimes make
offensive jokes
that is a toxic work environment so
again a toxic workplace is just a
workplace it's any workplace now that's
not to say that people should make
offensive jokes or even that your boss
should expect you to be available off
hours but these things happen and uh it
it and when when they happen it just
means that your workplace isn't perfect
it isn't flawless
indeed as Jimmy Fallon's staff
discovered it isn't a dream
there's no dream job
because life is not happening in a Dream
It's reality
stuff happens sometimes that you don't
like
that doesn't make it toxic you emotional
infants
and it certainly doesn't justify crying
fits or acting like you have PTSD
you didn't get your legs blown off on
the battlefield you answered a work
email at 7 pm you'll be fine
stop whining
see this is the real story with the
epidemic of toxic work environments once
again the problem isn't the problem
itself but the total inability of grown
adults to deal with the problem
you know there are always going to be
workplace pressures and angry bosses and
annoying co-workers
encountering these challenges that
doesn't make you an abuse victim it
makes you a normal adult existing in a
reality that won't always or in fact
will never
comport entirely with your dreams
you either learn how to cope with that
and succeed in spite of it
or you can cry like a toddler and look
for pity and a pat on the head
unfortunately many people these days
choose the latter
and for that they are today
canceled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts